welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am
your special temporary primary host of
the show uh today i'm joined by greg
knuckles he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for the time being we have
a lot of great stuff to cover in the
episode today but before we get into
that uh you might find yourself in a
position where you feel like
you enjoy the podcast and you feel like
you want to uh act upon that enjoyment
uh by supporting us and there are many
ways you could do that you could like
rate or subscribe wherever you get
podcasts you could join our email
newsletter by going to
strongerbyscience.com
newsletter
you can check out our coaches at
stronger by science we have a really
excellent experienced team of coaches
who do one-on-one virtual coaching for
training and for sports nutrition you
could use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com the code is sbs pod
gets you a five percent discount off of
your entire order uh you could subscribe
to the mass research review which is a
monthly research review where we cover
the newest science in uh training and
nutrition
and of course you could check out macro
factor that is the diet app that we put
together with a talented team of
developers and it does have a free trial
so you can take it for a spin and see if
you like it greg how is the road to the
stage going uh road to the stage is is
going pretty well uh i hit a new low of
226.6 this past week so i am officially
down 40 pounds since i started using
macro factor and i am in total
two-thirds of the way to my goal uh from
my previous high weight
of uh 278 point something trying to get
down to sub 200 uh so i'm two thirds of
the way there which is uh you know
that's that's a nice little
nice little mile post
um
[Music]
but uh yeah so looking forward
i'm in kind of a weird spot because like
objectively speaking like diet fatigue
is low like i feel
i feel good uh it's not hard to hit my
targets
uh but i also
just
for for reasons i can't fully discern
and feeling waning motivation
don't know why that is um
but yeah so i i don't know what the next
few weeks will look like may take a
little break may keep going but uh yeah
for now it's it's nice to hit that
little milestone you know a good way to
kind of give yourself a little jolt of
motivation
uh
ask myself
how would i approach this situation if
everyone
who i loved would die if i didn't meet
my goal that is a good way to do it um
and a pretty realistic way to frame it
too but i was thinking
i would just pick a show date
you know just circle it on the calendar
find the show order some trunks
let's make this thing happen
uh all right
road to athens here um
no major updates um
i've been super super busy uh doing a
lot of writing lately
and so i've been using the gym as kind
of a little
break to kind of clear my head and move
around a little bit use up some energy
it's basically like i work out when i
have writer's block i'm like all right
screw this i gotta move and get some
blood flowing maybe i'll have some uh
ideas floating around in my bloodstream
and if i increase cardiac output they'll
float to my brain that's kind of my my
thinking there
but the other day like i've been doing a
lot of basketball i mentioned previously
for whatever reason when i play
basketball um the
running posture like the uh the
mechanics of running while playing
basketball do not exacerbate any of my
hip issues the way that kind of standard
endurance running does
and posturally it's quite different you
know when you're dribbling a basketball
it looks very different from when you're
just like coasting through like a 11
mile run you know so basketball has been
a great outlet for me to get some cardio
in when i don't feel like swimming
and man the other day i was just uh
just kind of
beating the hell out of myself to to
just burn off some energy so i would
just go full court
uh there's no one around so i was just
going layups back and forth and back and
forth and back and forth full court uh
trying to really keep the pace up
and man
i just i kind of forgot how hard
basketball is when you're playing within
that context of like full court up and
back minimal rest yeah and like it
really makes like right now the nba
playoffs are on you develop a completely
different appreciation for watching the
game when you remember what it feels
like to try to do a skilled action or
activity when you're fatigued as hell so
like i would you know go do back forth
back forth back forth and then pull up
for a jumper
the task of trying to focus on executing
a skilled action like that when you are
absolutely gassed it just gives you a
completely different perspective i think
for some people who don't have a lot of
experience playing basketball you watch
the nba and you say
yeah like if i were 6 11 and my job were
to shoot all day you know in practice
like if i was shooting around you know
14 hours a week or whatever i'm sure i'd
be pretty good at basketball you know i
think it's
because nba players are such outliers
physically in most cases i think
sometimes there's a tendency to kind of
not fully appreciate the challenges and
demands of basketball yeah but man
just
go run some full court back and forth
six eight ten times and then try to hit
jumpers uh yeah it's
it restores your appreciation for the
absolute
unicorns that play nba basketball so
here's a here's a recommendation to you
or anyone else listening to this right
now
this is how i got really good at free
throws because i'm very good at free
throws uh so in middle school
we would do this drill at the end of
practice where everyone on the team
would just line up around the free throw
line
and um
like you know everyone would shoot two
and basically like you know middle
schoolers aren't particularly good
shooters and if you can hit like 70 of
your free throws in seventh grade like
that's that's pretty good uh and so
basically the coach would just have like
that number where
you know if we were shooting
uh it was more than this but just to
make the math easy uh if we were
shooting collectively 20 free throws
then if we
uh made at least 14 we didn't have to
run but for every free throw under 14
that was made
we had to run a suicide like free throw
line back half court back other free
throw line back full quart back um
and so
like during the off season
i was like hey you know that's
that seems like a good drill like
improve my free throw shooting get in
better shape and so i would do that with
myself uh where i would just shoot free
throws instead of running a full suicide
like i would shoot 10 and for every free
throw i missed i would run it down and
back and just repeat the process
and it works really well both for
getting just better at free throw
shooting because you're shooting a ton
of free throws uh for shooting free
throws well under fatigue um because you
are running a fair number of down and
backs and then also just for
conditioning because like what what you
were mentioning like it's far harder to
shoot when you're fatigued
um
like once i got quite good at shooting
free throws basically the way it would
go is for the first
five rounds you know i'm making 10 of 10
i'm making nine to ten things are going
well but once i maybe had
10 or 12 down and backs on my legs then
it would drop to like maybe
9 of 10 8 of 10
and then once i started making like
7 of 10 or fewer then the wheels would
just fall off and i'm just running
enough that like just percentages drop
uh horrifically and like if i can make
40 50 i'm feeling pretty good uh so if
you do that for like an hour it's
in out like but certainly by the end you
will have done a ton of conditioning and
it just gets harder and harder over time
um
but yeah that's uh
that's how i got good at shooting free
throws
yeah i mean that'll do it for sure and
it's way more engaging than just like
running on a treadmill for an hour yeah
yeah for sure
um all right so feats of strength what
do you got for us this week yeah so i've
got uh i think we both have
non-traditional feats of strength so
mine
is for a
strength sport
that
i don't know if we've ever talked about
it on the podcast but i think it's very
cool and that is arm wrestling and um so
john brzezink
is possibly
i can't even say possibly john john
berzink is the greatest arm wrestler of
all time like that's i i don't think he
would find
hardly any dissenters amongst that um
he i think won his first world
championship
in 1982
at at the age of 18
and
was basically like the top heavyweight
arm wrestler until
like
around 2010 give or take like he he
basically had a 30-year span of
dominance in the sport and when i say
heavyweight like he mostly competed at
body weights between like
200 and like 225 sometimes up to 240. um
but he was he was kind of like ed cone
there for a while where cohn competing
as a 220 would often times beat the
super heavyweights as well uh john
brzezink at a body weight at around 200
220
would sometimes just compete against the
super heavyweight arm wrestlers who were
huge and would beat most of them like
during during that 30-year reign of
terror
and um
but yeah so
just a tremendous career great longevity
uh and he was he was at the top or
basically at the top that entire time
but then he starts getting into his mid
to late 40s uh his results start
dropping off a little bit and like you
know he's
he's getting older like of of course
they're going to
and uh by the time he turned 50 like his
performance had dropped enough and he
was starting to accumulate some injuries
that he was like you know what it's been
a good career it's time to hang it up uh
so he did he retired i i think at 50 or
51 after after a career that no no one
would be able to find flaws in like just
no
there was nothing left to prove there
was no reason he would need to ever
compete again uh and i'm sure you see
where this is going uh he made a return
to competitive arm wrestling earlier
this year um
after seven years in retirement at the
ripe young age of 57 years old and uh he
is once again
and i i don't follow arm wrestling close
enough to have like a super strong take
about this but you could make the
argument that he is once again the best
heavyweight in the world and
if you would not sign off on that he's
certainly in the conversation um
so he's
he's not at a point anymore where he can
beat the top top super heavyweights uh
but against guys who are like
225
uh yeah he looks
like easily one of the top five guys in
the world again uh which
is is
absolutely bizarre because like even
when you think about
uh athletes with with great longevity um
you know
you you think about people who are still
able to compete at a high level in their
late 30s maybe into their early 40s
you don't think about people who retire
in their 50s stay retired for seven
years and then come back and aren't just
competitive but are once again among the
best in the world
so
it is
truly remarkable what he has already
accomplished and it is
i would say maybe even more remarkable
what he is uh accomplishing in this
moment and moving forward i'm just just
a tremendous athlete who uh who deserves
more respect
um i mean he has all the respect in the
world within the arm wrestling community
but you know that's it's not a sport
that people follow like it's not a sport
that a ton of people follow uh and even
myself as someone who's only like uh
roughly follows it a little bit i didn't
find out he was back until he'd been
competing for a couple months again
already um
but yeah so
if you if you don't follow arm wrestling
john brzezink is still someone you
should be aware of uh
just because like if you want to talk
about people
just across any competitive sport ever
who have had the greatest careers he
would have to be in that conversation
like his his dominance of the sport for
so long incredible and the fact that
he's able to come back and and keep
doing that at 57 uh just just boggles
the imagination yeah i can only think of
one kind of analogous situation where
somebody is at the top of a sport
retires
at a you know kind of an older age
relative to the sport and then comes
back and is quite competitive and i'm
thinking of george foreman
in boxing like he's one of the only
analogous situations i can think of but
we have an opportunity to see this once
again because as we know
uh tom brady had a lengthy retirement
from professional football but he has
returned so it'll be interesting to see
what what he um
looks like after about 13 days of
retirement it's gonna be exciting yeah
you could also throw satchel paige in
there
like i don't think he i don't think he
came back and like pitched full seasons
but
he would occasionally come in for like
an exhibition game i think into his 60s
and uh still still pitched at a high
level yeah
he would have been just fine in this era
because like
starters only throw like 50 pitches and
they're like all right get them out of
there yeah he would have been a usable
bullpen arm until like 75. yeah
yeah i was listening to a podcast the
other day that was lamenting like you
just
with the way that pitching has evolved
you just do not see a lot of complete
games anymore uh you know a starter back
in the day like i remember as a kid
you'd go to the ballpark and you'd see
like greg maddox is on the hill right so
you're like oh man that'd be incredible
you know if we see him doing
uh you know
if he goes like eight nine innings like
you would expect that you know in the
seventh inning he's gonna be on the hill
well and it would be good because it
would be a short game yeah greg maddox
was famous for for pitching a complete
game that would go like two and a half
hours yeah but but yeah it's just
totally different now dude earlier this
year uh
clayton kershaw had a perfect game going
i think through seven and they pulled
him yeah which like he did
theoretically that's like the right call
for
you know preserving an older arm like
you you don't want to
accumulate too much fatigue early early
in the season but but brother if you got
a perfect game going through seven like
the purist in me says you gotta at least
let him try yeah i shouldn't go out on
this limb because i'm not certain if
it's true but
you know the justification for pulling
him was like hey it's a long season we
want to keep him off the injured list
keep him in the rotation
i believe
he ended up getting pulled from the
rotation recently anyway
to try to manage his load so like the
idea was like hey we don't want to be in
a position where we have to take them
out of the rotation i think they did
anyway if i'm not mistaken um but yeah
so then after that people looked back in
hindsight and the people who were
already annoyed that he got pulled
they're like well he ended up on the
injured list anyway so like you know
good load management
uh but that might not be true so i
should probably stop discussing it at
this point i think i heard that but i
don't follow baseball very much
uh but you know what i do follow i've
got another feat of strength here that
you know you mentioned it's really
exciting to see kind of singular
instances of feats of strength but
longevity is important as well you know
putting together a career
uh of impressive feats
big don gorski
big dawn is a nickname i gave him but
don gorski
uh he just reached a milestone
he has been eating big macs
approximately every single day
for now 50 years i believe that in the
last 50 years he has only missed a
handful of days and it's been things
like
i believe it was like the day his mother
died uh a day where he he lives up north
i think in wisconsin
and so like a mcdonald's just didn't
open because like it was snowed in and
like no one could get to work yeah and i
even read that nowadays he buys extra
big macs and has him in the freezer just
to make sure something like that never
happens again so over the last 50 years
he has totaled over 32 000 big macs
which is it blows the the previous
record out of the water by a mile he
documents everything he keeps receipts
he even keeps boxes the little cardboard
box that the the big mac comes in uh so
like this guy has the receipts he's got
the proof um and i think it's safe to
say it's a record that no one will ever
touch
but he was also ahead of the curve when
it comes to the like if it fits your
macros like oh i'm gonna eat
twinkies every day and and prove to
everyone that it's okay uh
you know by every indication it looks
like he's still in pretty good health uh
every now and then he'll go like
get his cholesterol checked it's always
within normal ranges so
he's been working on that if it fits
your macros anecdotal experiment for for
50 years now and doing pretty good not
not a recommendation i wouldn't
necessarily say you should eat uh one or
two big macs a day but uh anyway
congrats to big dawn on passing 50 years
dude this guy was in uh he was unsuper
sized me wasn't he yeah he's he's he's
made a bit of a a bit of a cultural
impact he's been on quite a few things
yeah i i just searched him and i
i remember seeing him from super size me
and he he just seemed like a very
affable like hippie type guy with the
like
round john lennon style glasses but with
transition lenses just absolute king
[ __ ] that's awesome yeah man it's
incredible
all right so moving on we've got some
segments prepared for today getting into
uh some science i know our last uh
episode was very anecdote heavy the
pendulum is swinging back we're talking
uh we're talking science today so i
wanted to have a very brief research
review about sedentary time
just because i've been digging into some
of this literature and this kind of
builds upon uh some of your previous
segments about walking you know because
uh
a lot of times we think about sedentary
time and we think about okay it seems to
have an independent
deleterious impact on health and
wellness how might we rectify that and
one kind of proxy measurement you can
use is daily step count which which
you've kind of addressed generally
speaking if you have a pretty high step
count it's unlikely that you have
a tremendous amount of total cumulative
sedentary time because you're out there
walking a lot it also it at least places
an upward constraint on how much exactly
you can have yeah it's a proxy yeah it's
not a perfect indicator but generally
speaking if you have a high step count
that is likely to at least correlate
with
having
relatively lower total sedentary time
and theoretically relatively fewer
very prolonged stretches of continuous
sedentary time generally speaking if you
have a pretty high step count it means
you're getting up you're moving you're
walking and generally speaking having
less total sedentary time and hopefully
less continuous sedentary time as well
so just to kind of build upon that i
wanted to talk a little bit more about
the independent ramifications of
sedentary time and a couple other
strategies that you could use outside of
just monitoring step count because i
know for some people monitoring step
count you know there are some people
that really like to have a
very quantitative approach to their
health and wellness they like to track
everything they like everything to be
numerical uh and they can you know do
different types of interventions to
influence those numbers but i wanted to
talk about a couple other potential
strategies so first of all
it's important to establish that you
know you established very effectively in
previous episodes that low step count uh
seems to be associated with some
deleterious outcomes related to health
um
there are other meta-analyses that have
looked not just at step count as a proxy
but specifically looking at different
forms of sedentary activity and how
those relate to health and wellness so
for example there was a meta-analysis by
patterson and colleagues and i'm going
to link all three of these in the show
notes
but patterson and colleagues found that
total sitting time and television
viewing time were associated with higher
risks of several different chronic
disease outcomes and that was despite
controlling for physical activity so
we're talking about the independent
impact of sedentary time that you can't
necessarily offset by saying hey i you
know i go for a jog three days a week
like there is uh it's difficult to
defend the case
that regular participation in structured
exercise completely nullifies the
deleterious independent impact of being
sedentary for large portions of the day
especially for extended discrete periods
of time so patterson and colleagues
found this despite controlling for
physical activity
biswas and colleagues found significant
associations between sedentary uh
sedentary time and risk of a variety of
negative health outcomes related to
mortality and chronic disease incidents
and this negative impact from excessive
sedentary time it was certainly more
pronounced among people who had low
physical activity levels but
the association still persisted after
controlling for physical activity in the
entire sample
and then finally eklund and colleagues
found that sedentary time was
significantly associated with mortality
risk in individuals with low activity
levels low physical activity levels
and it was interesting because they did
some stratification by physical activity
level and you know like i said the the
the
association with negative health
outcomes uh
was or mortality risk i should say was
significant in the lowest uh third of
physical activity levels but if you look
at the high activity moderate activity
low activity kind of subgroups
within each of them you could see the
same pattern where
regardless of where you fall like having
high activity level certainly attenuated
you know especially like for this is
relevant to people who do structured
exercise it seems to attenuate the
magnitude of the deleterious outcome
from sedentary time but the general
relations relationship still persists
what i and what i mean by that is when
you look at the low medium or high
activity groups within those groups you
can see that relationship where the
higher your sedentary time gets
the more likely that you're going to see
an elevated risk of all-cause mortality
uh so
this is uh collectively the literature
indicates that you know certainly it's
good to do structured exercise and to
have you know a really intentional focus
on
getting out and doing discreet bouts of
physical activity uh but there's still
an independent negative impact of really
excessive sedentary time and we see
these kinds of things in
studies with athletes right even
competitive athletes you can look at
some some research where within a cohort
of competitive highly you know you know
really well trained athletes there are
still associations between sedentary
time and outcomes related to body
composition for instance i know
dr helms the other eric
reviewed a paper in mass a year or two
ago looking at the fact that
among really well-trained athletes
higher sedentary time was associated
with lower relative fat free mass and
higher relative fat mass so this stuff
persists even among people who have
a really high level of engagement and
structured exercise
so
what do we do about that i think that
there are two goals that you want to
have in terms of
offsetting some of these potentially
deleterious impacts of sedentary time
the first would be just reducing the
total cumulative sedentary time you have
throughout the week
the second goal i think is beyond that
effect if you can break up long extended
periods of uninterrupted sedentary time
there is some research to indicate that
that might be particularly beneficial
so you know i know there are
intervention studies where they will
look at some of the acute
cardiometabolic impacts of an exercise
bout and they'll find that those
acute benefits of structured exercise
can be really dramatically attenuated by
just doing like
four days of increased sedentary time
you know so we want to make sure that
you know and the way that they do that
is with long uninterrupted blocks of
sedentary time so um i think a strategy
for reducing total cumulative sedentary
time throughout the week is very simple
it's just planning out activities that
might not be structured exercise but
they are non-sedentary activities so
we can generally define sedentary
behaviors
as behaviors that are performed in a
seated reclined or lying position with a
net value uh less than or equal to 1.5
and met
is an acronym that is short it's not
really an acronym but they always
capitalize it
but it's short for metabolic equivalent
and
we had an interesting conversation off
air about how metabolic equivalents were
determined it's not the most robust
science
it's basically like back in the day when
research was very hard to do
they measured one dude who was 40 years
old and about 70 kilograms and they're
like how much oxygen does this guy
consume if we just sit him down in a
chair and measure it
turns out 3.5 milliliters of oxygen uh
per
uh what per kilogram of body mass per
minute yeah i think that's how it goes
uh and so yeah from there the met was
born the met is a standardized amount of
oxygen consumption per kilogram of body
mass per minute uh and so
you can debate you know how well that
transfers to different populations you
can and you should yeah yeah i say you
can debate there are many papers
explaining exactly why that number
doesn't transfer to a variety of
populations um but it kind of doesn't
matter that much if you're just using it
as a broad
uh
a broad metric for identifying different
general activity levels it still has
utility within that context
i would not use it for individualized
calculations of energy cost
of a specific exercise bout
there are better ways to do that which i
might get into at a later date
but if you're just trying to say hey i
need to break up my sedentary time the
way that you would do that is
look at a list of different types of
exercise or just general physical
activities and say hey i want to find
stuff that's at least higher than 1.5
mets and if you get over if you get into
the range of like 2 to 2.9 mets that
would generally be considered light or
low intensity physical activity so that
kind of sets a general range for for
where you would be
finding some degree of activity that is
beyond rest but not necessarily
structured exercise
and you might be saying well eric
there's so many potential activities
that one could do where would i find
such a list
and there's actually a tremendous list
that is publicly available
[Music]
it's uh there's a 2011
compendium of physical activities by
ainsworth and colleagues and it's openly
accessible you can download it and i
think it has
821 different physical activities at
different intensities as well uh so you
can go into that and and find
a lot of stuff i mean
mowing the lawn uh
you know uh
sweeping your house mopping the floor
uh all sorts of stuff
sitting walking at a variety of
different speeds uh
shoveling snow
i mean there are just so many different
uh types of extras or types of physical
activity listed here and they're
categorized into groups so there's like
bicycling conditioning exercises
dancing fishing and hunting home
activities home repair inactivity or
quiet kind of resting behaviors
lawn and garden miscellaneous playing
music occupational tasks
running self-care um you have like
self-care you know like bathing
taking medication uh hair styling like
so many different things in here even uh
religious activities if you joined me
on the uh the road to enlightenment i'm
sorry to say that meditation
only a met value of one oh that's rough
yeah some a shortcut to enlightenment
enlightenment but not a shortcut to
shredded uh you might but there are some
physical or some some religious
activities they got um what do they have
here uh there was one that was like 4.5
uh wait yeah they put moderate
moderate to heavy effort of manual labor
under religious activities um i'm not
sure how
that would all kind of work in there but
yeah maybe there's a way maybe you're
like building houses with like a
religious charity organization yeah they
do have volunteer activities as well in
here whoa that's that's quite the
category yeah yeah how do they assign a
met value to that uh they they have a
bunch of different you know okay okay
standing light moderate work standing
moderate lifting i i thought you were
saying that just like an exercise they
had was just volunteer
anything you're doing that is not
compensated is this number of meds yeah
i thought that's what you would never
say no it's a whole wild it's a whole
category where they talk about like you
know playing with with like chasing
after kids that you're you know
volunteering with like a youth group or
something the one i was looking for uh
praise with dance or run is a religious
activity with five mets whoa that's the
high met value i was searching for there
um but yeah so
basically the the short version of this
is for
just an enormous range of outcomes you
can find met values uh and kind of
engage in those activities to schedule
into your week certain different
discrete things you want to do
to
to break up your sedentary time and to
have some non-sedentary active
activities so this isn't the type of
thing that you would do every hour on
the hour but you could say you know what
on saturday i think i'm going to go mow
the lawn it has to be done anyway and i
can you know get some activity there
sunday i'll do some house chores you can
find in here dishwashing mopping
sweeping but you can start to move some
of these things throughout your week so
that you break up sedentary time and
maybe have one physical activity per day
or two physical activities per day that
are you know non-sedentary but also
not structured exercise but i should
mention
this list also has a lot of of utility
if you're looking to plan out different
forms of structured cardio as well so
for bicycling for example
they have all different intensity levels
for walking they have all different
intensity levels for different speeds of
walking
different grades of walking walking
forwards versus backwards like this is a
truly comprehensive and really
impressive list of activities so even if
you don't care about this podcast
segment but you exercise and you want to
have a general idea of comparing
intensity levels
that is linked in the show notes and
it's really really useful
uh another potential strategy which is
uh i think especially helpful for
breaking up
long periods of sedentary activity uh is
using something called exercise snacks
and this is something that's gotten
it's picking up some momentum in the the
peer-reviewed literature but it's
basically these really short isolated
bouts of vigorous exercise that are
performed for very short periods of time
but done periodically throughout the day
so
for example you might do three 20 second
intervals of vigorous stair climbing
like
literally what this looks like is you're
at your desk job in the office
step away from the desk
instead of walking to the water cooler
you go to the stairwell 20 seconds hard
catch your breath 20 seconds hard catch
your breath 20 seconds hard catch your
breath boom you're done for the hour and
so like you'll find different approaches
to this
concept of exercise snacks but generally
speaking it's you know you might do
something really short every hour on the
hour
but of course you can adapt that to it
every other hour there are also some
that are a little bit longer that are
kind of closer to like five minutes but
you would do them maybe every three to
four hours but the general idea is
scheduling in planned regular breaks you
know the the previous list of activities
was
more oriented toward
i'm going to do something that has a
a different purpose but i'm getting
physical activity as i'm doing it right
i'm mowing the lawn because my grass is
long but it's nice to know that i'm
breaking up my sedentary time but for
this it is exercise for the purpose of
exercise and it's done on a more regular
schedule and done several times
throughout the day and so what they try
to do with this approach is do uh
interventions with a lot of ecological
validity and a lot of practical utility
so they try to do things like stair
walking brisk walking air squats sit to
stand like basically chair squats
body weight calisthenics the idea is
that you could in a
a wide range of occupations
take a second go do this for three four
minutes
get back to your chair and not be
disruptive and not have to like drive to
the gym change clothes take a shower etc
so
this is an area of research that is just
getting rolling but
these are some nice strategies if you're
someone who was uh really
interested by greg's previous segments
about walking but you don't necessarily
do that well psychologically with a
highly
quantitative approaches to exercise if
you'd prefer to or if you just don't
have time to get in that many steps like
it is time consuming exactly yeah but
you know i the the time consuming
component is big but i've also seen
instances in the physique athlete world
where people
will tend to take things to extremes you
know psychologically is an extreme
endeavor and sometimes people respond
really unfavorably when you say hey try
to walk 15 000 steps per day and it's
like they are so fixated on that number
all day it's it's really uh detrimental
to quality of life for some people so
there's a lot of ways to break up your
sedentary activity and there's ample
evidence to suggest that it can be a
really positive thing to do so so i've
actually got
an anecdote related to exercise snacks
cool so back in the day uh
i think we've talked about this on the
podcast before i read a book uh many of
you have probably heard of called the
four hour body by tim ferriss
and uh
do not count this as a recommendation to
read that book there's uh
some good practical advice mixed with
some not so good advice
not the best signal-to-noise ratio
you'll come across uh but
one of the things he recommended uh
for
i think
completely incorrect reasons did has
actually turned out to be relatively
helpful for me um
so he had this whole section about just
like hey
how can you use the magic of nutrient
repartitioning
to
ensure that you can eat a bunch of food
and and not gain any fat he was like
well so look uh
yeah you have these these glucose
transporters and muscles and if you just
do 40 body weight squats before a meal
that's going to cause a ton of
non-insulin mediated glut4 translocation
all of those carbs you take in they're
just gonna they're just gonna go
straight to your muscles there's no way
they could possibly meet any other
metabolic fate so boom you've hacked
your metabolism uh and all it takes is
40 bodyweight squats wow and uh so yeah
that's
that's not true
uh but
um
you know when i first encountered that
information i was uh much dumber and
more naive and i was like okay okay i'll
give this a shot um
and
so i didn't i didn't uh
uh
notice
physical effects that
comported with what i was told to expect
in the book but uh what i did find is
just that doing some bodyweight squats
from time to time did just help me feel
mentally sharper and and kind of feel
better um so i've actually developed a
bit of a habit where
like not every time but most of the time
when i use the bathroom i just do like
20 body weight squats before i leave
while you're
using
uh
yeah i mean so it's it's it's good for
practicing your aim there's a
you know it makes a day-to-day activity
kind of like a mini game
that you might play in like a mario
party or something but no uh
no and afterwards um
and uh yeah like i i find that um
[Music]
you know it just helps get the blood
flowing i find that i have more
like i feel more energetic and just have
more mental clarity after that um
and yeah it's very simple so that's uh
something at least anecdotally that has
that has been helpful for me good stuff
um
now let's shift to some really important
topics here some
hard-hitting science about well i'll
just let you introduce it all right so
uh i've already made my juvenile joke
for the day yeah so
first first before i get into this
segment i just need to let you know that
this is one for the boys so
any women listening to this you need to
you need to turn it off right now or
just or just look at the time stamp skip
ahead to the next segment uh
this is not for you mostly because
we
as as the lads don't want you learning
our secrets to uh
you know figure out how how to get you
in bed so again this this is one for the
fellas uh any women still listening uh
just skip ahead
so all right all right all right lads
now that i know you're the only one
still listening uh
this podcast is finally taking the turn
all of you have been wanting this whole
time you're thinking hey evidence-based
fitness information that's fine
evidence-based nutrition information
cool i guess but ultimately i want
evidence-based information on getting
laid uh so you know we're finally taking
that turn
this is
uh science-based uh
uh
mating strategy advice
no so uh that is actually what i'm
talking about and uh i'm i'm doing this
because there is a new study that's been
published
that i that i've seen
um being shared
by
three
distinct but also interlapping groups of
people and that is uh fitness
professionals masculinity influencers
and in cells uh
way more overlap than uh
than one would hope and i will say these
these three groups of people are
uh by and large taking
somewhat different things away from this
study uh but i've seen enough fitness
people share this and i'm like yeah
whatever this is this is worth talking
about so the actual study uh
unsurprisingly isn't being shared around
that much but a press release i guess or
like an article about this study i have
seen um getting shared around quite a
bit
and the press release or article is from
realclearscience.com sounds sounds very
good very credible
um and the title of the article is the
male trait that best predicts men's
mating success so you know that's that's
quite the headline uh if you're a male
and you want to be more successful
mating you know that that might entice
you to click uh and maybe share it
and when you get into this article
um
i'll just read a bit of this and uh
you know you can just think to yourself
what what is the vibe that i'm getting
from this article about this paper
all right so it starts
in a massive meta-analysis that was
years in the making psychologists from
the university of durham and the
university of saint andrews in the
united kingdom explored how six
masculine traits a deep voice height
testosterone levels facial masculinity
finger digit ratio and strength
muscularity
impacted men's mating and reproductive
success
one trait was the clear winner so okay
we're one paragraph in uh you know it's
saying massive meta-analysis years in
the making like really hyping this up
and
one trait is the clear winner so that
that's leaving you with the implication
that this is
uh something you can really take to the
bank and also that that one particular
thing
uh is is having a far larger magnitude
of an effect than anything else all
right so
moving on the analysis which combined 96
studies looking at 177
000 subjects from around the world
across a wide variety of cultures was
published in february to the journal
e-life
and that's another thing worth noting i
did not see anyone talking about this
study when it was published in february
now that this article is published
seeing way more people talking about it
so once again this this is kind of
science by article not uh not people
really digging into the full text um
let's see lead author dr linda lip
lid boar whose academic focus is on the
traits that influence human mating
decisions and her colleagues found that
men who were more muscular and
physically stronger reported having more
sexual partners they also fathered more
children high testosterone levels and a
deeper voice predicted mating success to
a lesser degree but none of these traits
were linked to having more kids
masculine facial features like a square
jaw and a prominent chin were not
associated with increased mating or
reproductive success nor was a masculine
finger digit ratio in which the index
finger is relatively shorter than the
fourth digit or the ring finger
researchers say the results support the
theory that as humans evolved males
competed with each other for females
attention and that women usually chose
or were forced that's that's quite the
parenthetical uh to mate with the
winners and then here's a quote uh from
the authors in species with mail or from
the paper in species with male
intrasexual competition males tend to
evolve to become larger stronger and
more formidable than females as they are
in humans
uh so yeah that's that's the basic vibe
and then the last paragraph does note
that some of the
uh predictors were rather weak uh and
that you know they don't fully explain
uh human reproductive choices but maybe
only like 80 90
yeah they don't put numbers on anything
uh they basically just say hey here are
these things there are some associations
and of them uh
body masculinity is far and away the
strongest predictor so you read that and
you you would have every reason to
assume that like ah whatever they didn't
actually put any numbers in this study
but it at least has to be a pretty
meaningful predictor for
this article to exist as it does and
therefore you know people are sharing it
around fitnessy people saying like
hey guys like this is this is why you
need to come train with me like it's
it's really going to help help your
mating success uh masculinity
influencers saying
uh well incel saying what you would
expect them to say like this is why you
should take the black pill like it's
it's over for us who don't have
masculine facial features and are just
not naturally big and strong and then
like masculinity influencers basically
splitting the difference where it's just
like
yeah this is why you should get big and
strong and also why why
you're [ __ ] done for if you don't
whatever so
uh
you know all of that is well and good uh
this is the article being shared those
are the takes i'm seeing from it but man
it it sure would be inconvenient if you
could actually pull up the paper and uh
look at the strength of some of these
associations uh and so that's exactly
what i did and uh
when you
uh when you pull up this paper you can
you can just scroll straight down to
table two i will note free full text so
if you want to read this you absolutely
can um
so yeah just scroll down to table two
and and look at the strength of the
associations between
these various traits and mating success
which which is basically just like uh
uh how many sexual partners have you had
slash have you had sexual partners and
then there's a separate table for
uh reproductive success like basically
have you had kids
and um
yeah so for mating success
it is true that body masculinity which
was a composite measure of strength and
muscularity uh
what did have the strongest association
with mating success well there you go uh
and so just based on that little well
not snippet like basically the whole
article that i just read you just kind
of think to yourself like based on how
that article was worded how strong of an
association do you think there was
between body masculinity and mating
success you know probably at least a
moderate correlation maybe even a strong
correlation but no no dear listener
we're talking about an r value of 0.113
uh and so
you may be asking what does that mean
how do i interpret that so you can
square an r value and get
what is
very logically called an r squared value
or coefficient of determination which
basically tells you
how much shared variance there is
between
two measurements sometimes
sometimes that will be phrased as
how much does variation in one trait uh
or one measure explain variation in
another measure so the r squared value
we're looking at here is
0.017 so basically like 1.7
of the variance in in uh mating success
is explained by body masculinity uh and
you
i hope you're not thinking how much is
one point eight percent because it's not
much yeah yeah for for context here like
if you were gonna pretend that you had a
model that perfectly predicted an
outcome
you would intuitively need the r squared
of the entire model together to be 100
you have to predict 100 of the variance
in the outcome so yeah if you are
predicting
less than two percent of the variance in
the outcome
uh
that reflects the strength of the
relationship and the confidence level
you have if you say oh wow well it if i
manipulate that variable you know what
kind of an impact will that have on the
outcome yeah yeah so uh we we were
we were talking about this before we
started recording and sometimes in the
medical literature
you'll see a metric called nnt or number
needed to treat so basically like if if
you're testing a new treatment compared
to one that's already well established
and the new treatment tends to work
better nnt is basically just like
how many people on average would you
need to give the new treatment to before
on average one of them would have
meaningfully better outcomes than were
observed with the comparator treatment
um
so you know like
it it kind of helps like contextualize
things like if one thing does seem to be
better it shouldn't necessarily you
shouldn't necessarily expect it to have
like
way better outcomes for every patient
being treated like
you still there's still scale involved
like you need to treat a fair number of
people before
um you know the the differences kind of
become apparent uh so we we were kind of
joking that like maybe we need a metric
for research like this that's like nnf
like number needed to number needed to
[ __ ] like
you know like if you have uh a hundred
people with high body masculinity and
100 people with low body masculinity
like
how many more people have the have the
folks with high body masculinity taken
to bed like
maybe one or two in total like that
that's kind of the magnitude we're
talking about here for like what an r in
r squared value of of 1
1.7 means um
so yeah
all of which is to say this is
uh a tremendous example of something we
talk about from time to time
where
if you have enough data going into an
analysis uh
it's very easy to find things that are
statistically significant but
statistical significance and actual
practical relevance are two very
different things um
so
you know something that with
in a meadow with 177 000 subjects is
predictive of a particular outcome uh
you know if the strength of that
association is as weak as what we're
observing here
then like
the the actual practical relevance of
that outcome uh in your life very well
could be and probably would be
effectively nothing um
so that's one thing i wanted to touch on
next thing i wanted to touch on is just
that uh
just the level of confirmation bias i've
seen from from people sharing this
around like uh
folks folks who have a vested interest
in
trying to convince you to get as big and
strong as possible you know to buy their
coaching consume their content whatever
are sharing this to say like look if you
if you follow me on instagram you're
gonna get laid way more uh and
the results don't support that and then
on the other side like the the in-cell
type individuals that i've seen sharing
this it's just like yeah this this
confirms everything we've been saying
like the black pill
fully scientifically validated it's over
for us we have low facial masculinity
low body masculinity this major
meta-analysis confirms that no woman
will ever want to sleep with us so like
it's over boyos and like
once again no it it doesn't [ __ ] say
that uh
and so like
yeah this is uh
you know it's it's a study that i think
if you interpret it well uh
basically means that like these things
maybe there's some some degree of
predictive value in a large enough
population but like the practical
relevance to any discrete individual is
is virtually none um but man i i still
see people taking such big swings that
like whatever their world view is around
the value of body masculinity this study
confirms it uh which is very fun
um
and let's see the other thing i wanted
to touch on is like i mentioned before
the the concept of science by press
release um
like if if so like i mentioned i've i've
not seen people sharing this actual
study around i think that's partially
because like like science is is hard to
read a lot of numbers whatever a lot of
words as well uh it's
it's a lot easier reading articles or
press releases than it is uh original
literature
um
but also like
this article it's like the scientific
study itself
wouldn't be particularly shareable by
any of the people who i see sharing it
because if you're sharing this study and
your followers actually see the data
if they
have taken a basic statistics class they
could look at it and be like oh yeah
this none of this [ __ ] is predictive
like what is this person on about um
but yeah like there are a lot of the
a lot of the bad scientific
interpretations
uh that i see being shared around
oftentimes it's from a generally decent
study and then just the articles written
about the study like kind of suck um or
just like over hype it and then the
articles are what get shared and so the
perception of what the study says by the
people who have only read the articles
about the study doesn't actually match
particularly well what the study
actually says uh and and i think this is
it sounds like
you're referring to literally everything
that's ever been said about resveratrol
yes yes also that um
so uh yeah that's
that's most of what i wanted to say
about this study uh
i i wouldn't be surprised if you're
listening to this i wouldn't be
surprised if you see
either the real clear science article uh
pop up on on your timeline
or just some other article about this
study pop-up
and if you do just remember
r 0.133
r squared
uh 1.7 1.8
like that's that's the takeaway from
this study um
so yeah so just just be informed uh if
if you come across this bit of
information
the one thing i will note like a kind of
technical science-y note which to give
the authors of the actual study credit
they mentioned this as well
for their meta they assumed a linear
relationship between these traits like
basically that
uh you know higher body masculinity
would be predictive of greater mating
success
with you know
like basically across the spectrum like
if you go from
very low to low low to medium medium to
high high to very high uh that each
increase in those increments would
improve mating success um which tends to
be a pretty default assumption correct
with a lot of research questions if you
don't have
specific reason and theory to question
the linearity the most common default
assumption is going to be a linear kind
of relationship yeah yeah um
so that that was an assumption in this
meta-analysis but one of the things the
authors noted and this is a very
appropriate technical note is that if
you did have a non-linear relationship
there could actually be a strong
relationship that is just a weak linear
relationship and so like a great example
of that would be if you had a perfect
parabolic relationship and you tried to
fit a linear trend line to it the r
value would be zero because
you know it's it's a well-defined
relationship that is very poorly
explained by
a linear trend line um parabolic being
like an upside down u basically yeah
yeah um
so
you know that that could be the case
where you know it very well could be if
they did a non-linear analysis they
might find that like
moderate uh body masculinity was maybe
more associated with mating success and
then with similar drop-offs in mating
success with very high body masculinity
and very low body masculinity i'm not
saying that's the case i'm just saying
that uh
if they're using linear modeling that is
a possibility that can't be ruled out um
but
but that also doesn't lend itself
particularly well to the take on this
study that i see fitness people going
with where it's just like yeah
you need to get as strong and and jacked
as possible to in maximize your odds of
mating success like that
yeah so i i don't i don't know if there
is a non-linear relationship here just
saying like if there were you you could
still have like an actual relationship
that just
wouldn't be picked up by by a linear
trend line um
damn that's a weak note to close on but
whatever yeah that's that's all i have
to say about this it is a weak note i'm
not gonna i'm gonna argue with that but
it is that's why i'm the co-host yeah
but but it is uh kind of representative
of the fact that like when you
are presenting evidence uh
in a nuanced manner unfortunately it
doesn't lend itself to the uh to the big
finish you know where you say like oh
i'm gonna really hit the high note here
and walk off yeah um yeah it's it
science is nuanced and so like it's
it's very atypical that you get the
opportunity to write that big big
splashy headline that is fully
representative of a study finding
usually there's some more details and
you say here's what it tells us here's
what it doesn't necessarily tell us and
then you you pick it up from there but
yeah so the the biggest takeaway here is
uh
one for the fellas uh
like just do you if you if you feel
insecure like oh man like uh one one of
the other things to note um like i i
already mentioned this but i i really
focused
most of this discussion on on the body
masculinity bit because that was the
part that they
uh
that the article really really harped on
um
but yeah like if you're a short king out
there and you see this article being
shared around and you're like oh man it
also said that that height uh was
a predictor of of mating success where
taller people have it better uh that was
another statistically significant
relationship with an even lower r value
that was an r of
0.057 so
i mean that would be an r squared value
of like half a percent or like 0.3
percent uh so once again like if you're
a short king and you're like oh no like
the it's it's never going to work out
for me the
height height was not predictive of
mating success for all intents and
purposes uh if you're like oh no i'm uh
self-conscious about the fact that my
ring finger is longer than my pointer or
my pointer finger is longer than my ring
finger and that means i have low t and
that means no woman will ever love me
one
if that's a thought that's gone through
your head you consume too much in-cell
content stop it like any anytime you see
someone bring up digit ratios never
listen to them again um
uh yeah or if you're like oh no i don't
have a strong jawline also don't [ __ ]
worry about it not predictive uh yeah
just like just like chill out be you be
a cool person treat people well and uh
yeah stuff should work out
good advice
all right so i've got a quick segment i
want to do on high intensity interval
training
i'm considering it a coach's corner
because i'm not going to do a super
thorough dive in the literature but this
is another instance of me kind of seeing
things on social media that is kind of
wrapped in this evidence-based label
and i saw
you know someone make this claim and
then a lot of people who purport to be
very evidence-based sharing this claim
and i kind of wanted to clear uh or kind
of set the record state
set the record straight here so the
claim i saw somebody like kind of made a
position also
uh welcome back ladies we're oh yeah
we're glad for you to rejoin us yeah
after skipping that last segment welcome
back
uh so the claim that i saw was it was
all about high-intensity interval
training which i will call hit
and uh the whole idea was like listen if
you're doing
hit if you're doing true high-intensity
interval training like you should not be
able to do a work interval that's longer
than like 30 seconds like if you if you
can do this for 45 seconds or a minute
like
bad news you're not doing hit and like
if you think that you're
your you know group exercise class or
your boot camp class is doing hit like
you're kidding yourself and also you're
a joke so like the whole idea was like
you know only very few of us are tough
enough to actually do interval training
we all puke when we're done with it and
if you're not puking or dreading you
know your workout it's not actually high
intensity interval training and so i saw
people sharing it and commenting saying
yeah you tell them good stuff and the
reason i it
rubbed me the wrong way
was like this was largely kind of
the vibe to me was to discourage people
who are engaging in some of these other
forms of higher intensity exercise that
doesn't fit a very specific paradigm of
interval training you know so like
calling out like a group exercise class
or a boot camp class that's usually
people who are like beginner or
intermediate exercisers not always but
often and so they're they're trying to
engage in other forms of exercise and
enjoying it and feeling good about it
until they open up their phone and they
see everybody just [ __ ] on them for
for entertainment i don't like the way
that it makes high-intensity interval
training seem in inaccessible to a large
portion of the population that was my
first concern my second concern was
it's not true
it's it's wrong
it's false it's fake news it's any
combination or permutation of words that
mean hey that's not a true statement so
like what really bothers me is
saying i'm gonna dunk on people in the
name of evidence-based fitness by the
way i've never engaged with this
evidence i've never opened up one paper
about high intensity interval training i
have no idea what's going on in that
research uh so yeah it just kind of
rubbed me the wrong way because
man would you believe that
one of the most common high-intensity
interval training interventions that you
will ever find in the literature
involves a four-minute work bout so it's
it's four minutes of exercise at a high
intensity followed by usually about
three minutes of kind of the rest
interval or the lower intensity interval
so have you ever considered that maybe
the people in research who
defined what high intensity interval
training means
actually don't know what high-intensity
interval training is well correct that
that is kind of the underlying premise
of this type of post is like i am going
to set a definition for this that is
fully contradictory to
all of the scientific evidence that has
determined what this intervention is and
what it does yeah but also it happens to
be evidence-based yeah so figure out how
to make that work for me
but yeah so basically it was just a
really annoying post to me because it
discouraged people from engaging in
these forms of exercise that might but
that might be quite helpful to them and
again it was using evidence-based
fitness as a label to dunk on people
while fully contradicting and
misunderstanding the totality of
evidence so if you're interested in high
intensity interval training like there
have been so many protocols out there
i'm looking at a table from a review
paper
a review paper that i'm going to link in
the show notes but you could do you know
10 work intervals that are one minute
long eight that are two minute long
seven that are three minutes long four
that are four minutes long uh 30 second
work intervals i mean you you will find
a huge range of
work in interval durations and a huge uh
variation in the the kind of ratio
between work interval and rest interval
but generally speaking if you look at
the literature you can call something
high intensity interval training usually
if you're getting above
85 percent of your you know predicted
maximal heart rate or measured maximum
maximal heart rate and some some will
even define that threshold as low as 80.
like i mean we are not talking about
completely exhaustive exercise bouts
here we are talking about getting your
heart rate up to
80 85 percent of max heart rate
sustaining it there for anywhere from 15
seconds to four minutes uh based on the
literature uh and and kind of repeatedly
doing that so i sincerely think that the
publication of the tabata study is one
of the most harmful things that has
occurred in scientific history that's
that's an exaggeration i'm being
hyperbolic and not because it's a bad
study but just like that that i think
has become the default mental model for
people like what
appropriate intensity is for like high
intensity interval stuff and like the
whole purpose of that paper was just
like what if we took people who are
already really highly trained and put
them on like put them through a way
higher intensity protocol than has been
used previously um but yeah like that i
i think that's like the mental model
that people work with when it when it's
like
uh kind of defining training intensity
for high intensity interval training but
like that that paper is is an outlier in
terms of the types of intensity they
used yeah and another common way to do
it um people saw some of these modified
wingate approaches which is
fits the definition of sprint interval
training rather than high intensity
interval training you can consider
sprint interval training to basically be
something of a subset or kind of a a sub
type of high intensity interval training
and if you're doing sprint interval
training that is a maximal exhaustive
bout in the vast majority of cases and
those do tend to be pretty short and
have pretty uh pretty
large ratios of rest interval to uh to
work interval so for example this got
big in the natural bodybuilding world
i'm gonna sprint until i puke for like
30 seconds on a bike and then i'm gonna
rest for like
two minutes or three minutes or four
minutes and try to work up the courage
to do to do another and basically people
would do a few of those sprints and say
this is how we define interval training
and anything else is fake it's it's just
not an evidence-based
claim and it
very directly contradicts the vast
majority of evidence that we have
related to high intensity interval
training and i was going to do a longer
segment where i talk a little bit about
the pros and cons of interval training
and how to incorporate it into a
concurrent program for someone who's
lifting and doing interval training but
it literally looks like the world is
ending outside uh
this weather is disastrous so i'm not
sure how much longer we're going to have
power
also
we're getting pretty close on time here
so i'm going to say the longer hit
segment for next episode uh because yeah
i just don't have faith in any of our
equipment continuing to work for more
than a couple minutes here um this is
actually really it's a shame i was
looking at a map on on like a
meteorology website and tornado alley is
just like shifting east and so like yeah
i i used to like i used to find it very
comforting that i moved far enough east
from ohio that i'm like oh i'm i'm not
going to see a lot of tornadoes yeah and
it seems like it seems like we're
getting more and more of those and uh
yeah the the meteorology patterns would
suggest that tornado alley is just
consistently creeping further and
further east we're not squarely in it
yet but yeah there's uh there's some
nasty stuff going on yeah like i i don't
i don't know how much of this is coming
through the mics because i think the the
pickup field is calibrated pretty well
but it's
it's loud out there the
the wind is is deafening uh it's
currently 4 15 p.m
uh
you know in in the late spring in north
carolina should be very bright it looks
like the sun went down about 45 minutes
ago um
we we might be facing the end of days
so who knows this
thi this episode might if someone
uploads it it might be our letter from
beyond the grave so uh i also i don't
know if i mentioned this which is the
best i'm not sure if i mentioned this on
the podcast but recently a tree like
kind of fell on my house yeah uh and so
man every time the wind blows i get like
a little knot in my stomach uh and
yeah i i would i wouldn't mind knowing
what's going on back at the house right
now and almost as catastrophically the
last time it got windy it blew over
several of lindsay's potato plants so
there's god yeah i mean there are plenty
of casualties for this this sort of
weather event yeah dude it it snapped a
full-grown extremely healthy pine tree
in my yard and
if it yeah it was very close to doing a
tremendous amount of damage but geometry
helped me out a little bit but all right
so anyway let's wrap this thing up yeah
we're going to wrap it up next episode
i'm going to talk in a little more
detail you know i already talked about
hit has a broad definition it should be
very accessible to a lot of different
people it's even used in cardiac rehab
settings and different clinical
populations in the literature but again
to know that you have to interact with
the literature so make sure your
evidence-based fitness professionals
every now and then
check in on
what we might consider evidence
uh
i i
sounds like a really stringent set of
characteristics that i'm demanding but
that's kind of part of the definition i
think that's a bar most people should be
able to clear yeah all right to play us
out what do you got greg uh how about
how about you do yours because i'll have
more uh
real world uh experience with mine next
time we record
okay so you're gonna push it to the next
episode okay so uh you know we often do
these media recommendations to play us
out and and i've kind of uh
assumed that i just exist
completely separated from media and
entertainment but i did more thinking
about it and that's not true so i don't
watch a lot of television or movies i
really don't watch much at all to be
frank but i do interact with a lot of
music and i listen to podcasts every now
and then so i have decided i'm also
going to give media recommendations they
just won't be television or movies so
i like music because i can listen to it
while i'm doing things music while
driving music while working out music
while uh doing work sometimes so i want
to start giving some pot some music and
podcast recommendations my first one of
course has to be radiohead it's my
favorite band ever by a wide margin also
jeff nippard's favorite band uh to the
best of my knowledge
so interesting correlation there i
he's pretty strong so you know muscular
people perhaps if you listen to the
music they like
i'm speaking about jeff here not me but
jeff jeff is a freak and he likes
radiohead so that's good
um so radiohead if you're not familiar
uh they've been doing an album every two
to five years since 1993
so they have nine studio albums uh
dating all the way back to 93. when i
hear like a tv recommendation and
someone says great news there's 15
seasons that are all 20 episodes long i
say
absolutely not i don't want anything to
do with that because it with a show you
want to work your way through its
entirety it's almost more feasible to
deal with a show that has a less
complete archive of of episodes
but with music you want it to be a huge
kind of deep pool of music so that you
can continue to explore different sounds
and different albums and things like
that so i have a completely inverse
relationship with music where i love
hearing about a new band and i say oh my
god they've got you know six seven eight
albums like that's great so
i have
i don't have a favorite radiohead album
but you can organize them into tiers
based on how accessible they are because
some of radiohead's albums are extremely
experimental and if you dive right into
those it might be a bit difficult to
pick them up but easy access if you're
like hey i'd like to check out this band
and see what they're all about the benz
and hail the thief are very accessible
to a general listening audience the next
step up you'll see albums like ok
computer in rainbows the king of limbs a
moon shaped pool those are more like the
moderate range
if you want to do a deep dive you can
listen to kid a and amnesiac those are
their most experimental albums and then
finally you can listen to pablo honey
that's their first album and if you
listen to all the others and then that
you'd say absolutely not this cannot be
the same band i refuse to believe it so
i wouldn't start with pablo honey
because it's my least favorite album of
theirs by far it's their least favorite
album of theirs they kind of refuse to
play it when they when they play shows
um and no one's really asking for it
anyway um but yeah so pablo honey i
would say to the end just almost as like
a museum exhibit of like holy crap how
did we get from from there to all the
rest of their their albums but
each album is its own thing and they
even have a lot of side projects you can
get into uh their lead singer tom york
has had a ton of side projects almost
every band member has has done some uh
pretty high profile um
solo work and then johnny greenwood the
guitarist has done some really popular
film scores so he did there will be
blood phantom thread you were never
really here spencer the power of the dog
and many more and those were like pretty
big movies that so you've probably heard
music from members of radiohead simply
through viewing the films that i've
never seen um and and the nice thing
about radiohead i've already mentioned
this huge you could go through their
studio albums uh
their uh film scores their their solo
projects their side projects but some of
my favorite radiohead songs are actually
b-sides or unreleased tracks that never
made it onto an album so like
i've been digging into their their
entire library of music for
15 years and i still find new songs and
i say i think this might be one of my
favorites you know so if you're looking
for a band that has like a huge archive
of you know huge library of songs that
you can really dig into with a lot of
different sounds from album to album i
couldn't recommend radiohead highly
enough and i'll be given some more
recommendations in the future sounds
good
all right so uh we better shut this
thing down before we lose power uh but
this is a normal length of an episode
anyway so we did well
um as always thank you very much for
listening and we will be back in one
week i hope with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode finally please remember that we
are not medical doctors or registered
dietitians so before you make any
changes to your exercise or nutrition
habits be sure to check with a qualified
health care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you